yes you might
ch right good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the meeting of the auditing
governance committee on Tuesday the 14th
of November
2023 the first item on the agenda is
apologies for
absence so Kirsty do we have any n chair
none received
okay um Declaration of interests members
with interest should refer to the
agender item describe the nature of
their interest when the item is
considered item three agreements of
agenda items part one and two we have no
part two items this afternoon I come
in so urgent matters brought forward
from with the permission of the chair I
have
none and so on to item five which is
audit of the 2022 23 statement of
accounts Pages 3 to 45 to receive a
report from Grant Pon so Andy over to
you if I can just start off chair if
that's okay just by recing to the to the
committee where we are and where we've
come from so so back in late September
um we had the 2122 accounts represented
before the committee these had these had
been through some significant changes
due to the pensions valuations so it was
back in September that these were
represented formally to the authority
and also we received the audit Bings
report for
2122 so moving on we're now um back
where the the Associated changes have
now been put through 2223 and the bulk
work of the audit for 2323 has been
completed and these are presented to the
authority at an additional item um but
yes but today's purpose where we've got
Andrew Bailey with us to talk through
the audit findings report and to talk
through the the work that's been
undertaken on the financial accounts for
the
last thank
you thank you thank you chair um so this
the the report that's on the agenda is
our our audit Finance report and
basically summarizes the uh the findings
of our work the 2223 financial
statements and and the value the value
for money work um as it sets out on page
five of the report the our work is
substantially complete um and and
subject to the completion of a couple of
number of items set out there in the
bullet points on page five we we expect
to issue a an unqualified audit opinion
um there's there's been a small number
of changes noted as part of the audit
some of those are kind of are if you
remember back2 where we had the as
Gordon said the U the restatement due to
the pensions and then a bit of a change
on the depreciation on the pp notes
those are things that have by default
changed the opening position in 22 23
accounts so therefore they've just been
reflected
um since since this report was written
we've made progress against those bullet
items there on page five with the only
things now outstanding are some
completion of our work on the property
plan and Equipment valuations which is
the biggest area of work that we do and
it's it's quite detailed and and I'll
come on I'll go through the significant
risk S one by one and I can update on
that as we go and then the the other
item is the the receipt of the pension
fund uh letter of assurance from the
auditor of the uh Devon pension fund um
again it's another
complex audit that invariably every year
despite how much resource we throw at it
always seems to present US problems
there's some additional testing that
need to do in there because they found
but nothing that we're expecting to
impact on on the um on the opinion for
all the admitted
bodies value for money wise um and this
is just the high level messages on on
this I'm just covering so value for
money we had a plan to we've got a bfm
specialist coming to do that work the
bfm specialist has has broken her leg
unfortunately she's at to have surgery
so we're looking to get replacement in
with the aim still being to try and get
that AIT report to the January meeting
to close off this this AUD period and
then leading to that Handover to the
next to the next
Auditors the one thing I would like to
say before I go into a bit more detail
is that you know at the start of here we
had a in our audit plan we had other
risk and that was around the capacity of
the finance team because with with David
and and BR there was quite a few changes
within that team um
and actually you know my reflection is
that the 's gone really well and I think
the team of um the finance team have
responded to all our queries as you know
as as quickly as they've been able to
have been supportive of the audit
process and I feel that the two teams
have worked worked really well together
so that's just a sort of recognition of
of of Gordon's team um and and Gordon's
support you know throughout the process
so in terms of just a little bit more
detail now uh I'll just take take
through the
um just take you through some of the
detail just so that especially around
the significant risks and then I'll I'll
pause and I'll take any questions on on
anything that that the committee might
have questions on so that our strategy
our a strategy set out in our audit plan
didn't change largely it did a little
bit on the group side of things and come
on to that that shortly and the
materiality which is which is
effectively the number that if there was
an error bigger than that we would
qualify the accounts and we would we
would reflect that in our opinion that
didn't change either so that's that
remained at £700,000
and then the important thing for for
those charge with governance for this
committee is that triviality which is
£335,000 that also didn't change and
that is where if there was an error
above that that was what would find its
way into this report other items below
that we would deem as trivial and they
would just either be corrected or
amended or where youve got little you
know punctuations and things like that
that have changed throughout the process
just really sort of picky things they
wouldn't then find the way into this
report so if we move on to page
10 page 10 is and the first risk there
we've got is management management
override of control and that is the the
presumption that within every audit
there's a risk of Fraud and we can't rep
that risk that that has to that has to
remain there we cover that off through
our work on journals and through
estimations and um where where
management have made estimations within
the accounts that's where we focus that
word because that is those are the areas
where management if they wanted to
that's where they would potentially
manipulate the financial syst position
so we've done we've done a lot of work
in that area because that's a big part
of the work we do journals is quite
substantive amount of testing and we
haven't identified any issues that we
need to bring to the committee's
attention on the next page on page 11
we've got improper Revenue recognition
and expenditure recognition now
expenditure
recognition we we rebutted that risk as
part of the audit plan for both the
council and for the group because of the
controls that are in place and we were
happy that we didn't perceive that to be
a risk on Revenue
recognition the the presumption is that
Revenue might be recognized when it
shouldn't have been recognized now for a
council we we normally would rebut that
because most most income comes through
uh through grant funding and things that
are quite easily controllable easily
reconcilable so we would normally re
that what we didn't do at the planning
stage we we don't rebut that for core po
entities so for active torage we didn't
rebut that presumption because at that
point in time we thought that the income
would be material and therefore we would
need to rely upon the external ores of
active torage to get Assurance over
their revenue
figures however on and this is where I
mentioned earlier about a slight change
to our audit strategy in terms of the
group because when we received TR
financial statements and we looked at
the the group working papers the actual
amounts that are Consolidated in are
below our level of materiality on both
income and expenditure so
therefore it's below material so the
risk of actually improper revenue
revenue recognition being materially
stated it it it couldn't happen so on
that basis we've then moved to reut
revenue for the group and we changed our
strategy in terms of not relying upon
active Tores auditors because we didn't
need to all of our work was centered
around agreeing the consolidation
adjustments in terms of the group in
terms of those Intergroup
transactions so valuation of Landon
buildings on page
12 again no no issues to date we've
substant you know we are a good chunk of
the way through this we've got sort of
two or three sample items left to finish
uh I'm completing that work myself and
at the moment there's no there's no
issues that I need to bring you to your
attention on that um again it sets out
there that just that that depreciation
change but that was something we found
in 2122 and has then just been reflected
through into the 22 23 22 23
accounts pensions again you know we've
got the we got the restatement because
the trian reevaluation that obviously
changed the opening position
for the 2223 accounts because 2122
changed and that's just that's just
builted through our work today hasn't
identified any issues with the with the
pensions Li with the pensions valuation
however we're still waiting for the
pension fund Auditor's letter of
assurance which just which gives us
Assurance over the assets held within
the fund and then obviously a percentage
share of those then are what's been
reflected into tor's account so we need
that overall assum before we can close
we can close off that area of
work so on on the group on page 14 that
was our other significant risk and it it
was only a significant risk purely
because it was the first time that the
the council prepared group accounts that
was the only reason it was there the
numbers involved weren't you it wasn't
overly complex group one one company
um I think it was quite I was quite I
was quite pleased with the way that the
group was put together I felt like it
was the working papers are good you know
really supported the group made the work
relatively relatively straightforward um
there was a coup there were a couple of
changes which is just set out on there
that were that were reflected um in the
revised
accounts um but but generally the
working papers good and and the support
because the I think I said to it earlier
when I was talking about our work on the
group was all
about you've got if you think about
you've got active Tores accounts you've
got the council's accounts they come
together and the way you get to your
group position is by then all the
Intergroup transactions so where so
where the council pay over the
management fee for to active torage
that's obviously shown as expenditure in
one set of accounts income in another
set of accounts so what happens on
consolidation those items are canceled
out
so all our work because the end product
was immaterial was all around testing
those transactions and we tested 100% of
those and we did not identify any issues
with with that um there is one reporting
item there in terms of an unadjusted
misstatement um and to be honest we
didn't ask the council to adjust it
because as part of our final procedures
we we we wrote to the Auditors of active
torage and asked for their audit
findings report their management letter
and within that there was an adjusted
misstatement of £35,000 which is set out
in the report to do with an
overstatement of
bat now obviously as that's Consolidated
in if it's overstated in those S of
accounts it's overstated in the group
position here but because the amounts
not Material we we we we didn't request
that that was that was adjusted
the next few pages talk about the key
estimates and the work that we've done
on those again I won't go into any great
detail on those um you know I think sort
of page 17 is probably the one that that
that's what underpins the pensions
changes and the liability there and you
know it's how it sets out how we've got
the assurance that all the different
assumptions that are made by the actu in
coming to that valuation
we use PWC as our as expert they do a
lot of work in this and they say right
all the assumptions should be in this
range and that table there clearly shows
that those values are within within
those ranges so that gives us comfort
that you know that there's not going to
be a massive difference because one a
one percentage change in any of these
numbers on such a big number is itself a
big
number
and why we had the thing around the
triangual reevaluation the need to
change
that I
think in terms of the detail I think
that's all I was going to cover really I
think the only other things I just
wanted to quickly confirm is that
there's no Independence issues that I
need to bring to you attention in terms
of our in terms of our own our own
independence um and the fees are as set
out in the audit plan when we presented
that they they remain
unchanged I I'll pause their chair
that's okay I'm consci we talk talked a
lot there but I'm happy to take any
questions well thank you much Andy I
think that's a very comprehensive review
and I think it shows the working
exceptionally well which if you take
that back for
the
um
you know that's a very robust audit and
with Master BL
colors thank
you councelors do you have anything you
wish to
ask David to do with land valuations
this fluctuating Market how how are they
sort of really established and uh we I
know we used to have a asset man
management think didn't we with all bits
and pieces that were scattered around
the district after which many of us
didn't know existed really is is that
they all on that list when you do these
land valuations because I'd like to see
that at some stage me I to look at what
the various Parcels of land around know
bit of a dispute about one east of water
where the district no we don't we don't
know well yes you do because prevented
the Town Council from doing anything
with it so say that's not the only
little part land hanging around your
District yeah all all all the land in
the buildings is all held within the
council's asset register as part of our
work we agree the numbers in the
accounts to the asset register the asset
register is then populated and updated
each year based on valuations that have
been undertaken for that year those
changes and those numbers that change
those are the ones that we AED so in
terms of like you know is everything on
there yes we're comfortable the asset
register is complete and that then feeds
into the uh the financial statements
right okay thank
you st um again on the page 12 valuation
say the property is revalued every five
years yeah ex external valuation value
are youing I'm assuming yes so so in
terms of what's uh the every five the
code requires that that at asset should
be revalued every five years so what
what a lot of um what a lot of councils
do is they'll they'll
revalue
20% each year and within that they'll
probably look at their big ones as well
because the big ones will be in there
every year they go 20% and then over the
fiveyear period on a rolling program
just gets revalued to is slightly
different to that in that it does it
does its 20% full Val valuation where
there's all inspections and everything
else but actually for the other
80% there is also a desktop revaluation
done as well so so each
year effectively tages are
revalued
100% which is is a lot better position
to be in than where you've only done the
20% in some ways because the risk
of material difference because if you
you imagine you not really valued
something for four years there could
have been significant movement on that
there could be a lot of
dation OBS damage to the building all
these things that could happen where at
least with the with the indexation the
the the 80% being covered it gives quite
a bit of comfort that actually the
valuations are are fairly are fairly fa
up to St which is is good yeah that's
the
surprises exactly you are external value
isues yes yes so it's the it's the
district the district value um do Tes so
that's that so they and but they sign up
for the for the whole the whole 100% so
yeah but the district value being a
external body independent of council
right not not sort of the commercial
World
joes or sa yeah I mean
different councils do have it could be
somethingone like that I mean we go
through tending process but it's a
district valer that that has got the
work to to to value our assets yeah and
they're all rigs qualified surveyors
plus they've got this additional
qualification in valuations as well
before we commission them yes it's just
trying to differentiate the difference
between District value and from a
commercial world the names are mentioned
or some of the names are mentioned as
long as they were qualified we go the
district just the name of the the the
body
that's it could incorporate in it does
incorporate some of those names could
yeah yeah thanks for that
um is it I'm not sure if it's relevant
to this particular committee chair the
work you just mentioned is tended for
yeah and is that something that's
available to ask questions on at this
committee or or should that be a
different committee chair in other words
what charges are we making for the audit
yes for the valuation for the
evaluations yeah yeah I don't have that
information afid but get it I just
wondered wasn't true relevant question
to ask this uh this committee there it
certainly valid that there are a number
of associated costs not just Fe but the
actual aial fees valuation fees that
that occur every year that it's pended
for anyway yes yes I'm well aware of the
the structures can vary quite a lot yeah
in terms of uh the valuation fees that
can be applied um then one other thing
on page
14 um it's a statement that impa curs on
page 12 it's dying and have to keep
rebooting
it um and it may be the way I'm reading
this but let's stick to page 12 we've
got the under risks identified in our
audit plan
uh the bottom last paragraph um we
therefore identified valuation of London
buildings particularly re evaluations
and impairments has a significant
risk
um that am I reading that wrong is that
should we is that sounding alarm Bells
significant risk so so
chair yeah so what that that's just
that's our terminology so when we when
we do our audit planning we we identify
the risks what we perceive to be the
risks of significant for material
misstatement so that's why we call them
RIS because and and the two big ones are
always the pensions liability and
property plant and Equipment because a
small change you all if you think about
a property valuation there's a lot of
assumptions that a valuer makes in
coming to those end end figures so and a
little change in any one of those
assumptions if they are incorrect would
impact the end figure quite
significantly because you you got
percentages being applied to to big
numbers and therefore the impact would
be big so when we say there're
significant risks they are significant
risks because that's where the risk is
however we've now done our work and
we're happy that that risk hasn't hasn't
hasn't come to provision but the risk
still remain and that will be you
know next year you'll have different
Auditors they'll sit here they'll have
an audit plan and without any
significant change to the code two of
the big significant risks that they will
have will be pensions liability and PP
and poerty planting equipment because
they're the biggest numbers on the
council's balance sheet it's the same
risk at every count every Council across
the country will have those risks there
might be other ones as well for example
in in this AUD finings report we've got
group because it was the first year that
the group had been prepared the council
had never done that
before we as part of our risk assessment
we thought well actually there's a
chance that might go wrong and they
might consolidate the wrong figures so
therefore there's risk that actually
that could be could be materially mistak
so we put that in as a risk and then we
we responded to that risk with the with
the work that we've said out here to
make sure that we're comfortable albe it
on the group one that did change
slightly because of because of the
numbers when they came through we're
like actually it's not such a
significant risk now because we we can
do the work ourselves okay so as I say
what you're saying there in my summary
language is you identify the risk on one
side of the page on the other page to
set out what you're doing to offset that
risk yeah
exactly one final point the valuation of
plant and equipment is that done
externally
yes yeah the
same well there's not much
valuation for the most part it it would
be in the situations where it was
intrinsic to a building that it would be
that it would be subject to evaluation
so so vehicles or stock or items like
that wouldn't be subject to valuation I
say yeah because they insant but I think
I probably misled you a little bit
because our risk if you look on there
our risk is the valuation land and
buildings and I keep ping the property
planting equipment which
quickly I'm sort of what I'm saying is
Fally incorrect because the risk is on
the land and building that's where the
valuation is equipment is is valued at
historic cost infrastructure again is
the storic cost of basically what you
pay for it so there's there's less
there's less risk in that because if you
if you buy if you buy a computer the
computer is you know is a computer is a
computer that's what it cost and it just
gets depreciated then in terms every
year but it's not
revalued um it doesn't it doesn't change
in valuation other than through
depreciation it's the land and buildings
element that is where we've pinpointed
that risk across the pp balance so
apologies
for slightly on on my
terminology I understand what you're
saying my question was more aimed at the
plant and equipment by that I don't mean
office qu but more say for instance
obious of the council Au is responsible
for waste collection for instance
significant amount spent on planting
equipment it's recently been
renewed and there's obviously when
that's renewed does
that audit of that process does that
come before this
Committee just looking at the
overarching title of the committee a
audit and governance you referring to
Vehicles yes just to give you an example
yeah yes they' be included within the
fix static register they be included
within the balance sheet yes is that
reviewed obviously I think this from um
memory they're replaced every five years
of so if they're Dev devalued
depreciated on a straight line basis is
that then examined at the end of the
five years for when they are
replaced the depreciation value ratio is
correct you say if you depreciate a
straight line basis over the five years
at 20% per year or written down to
nothing or if there actually residual
value that then taken into account to
adjust the depreciation value over the
next life of that plan in equitment
within the accounting policies you'll
see that our assumptions around
depreciation will be stated so those
kind of issues we stated and it might
well be the case for an auditor if we
perhaps over or understate is the the
life of the assets then it would throw
up an eror yes and if it was L it's
probably difficult to imagine an era
large enough um that it was material
interest to the a but they might still
highlight that there was a difference
and they might encourage us to change
our accounting policy to to have a more
realistic lifespan in particular C of
asset I guess that depends on how many
waste collection you big they are
massive
bigger Tes
smaller
yeah anyway thanks very
much any further
questions okay I'll
back um well in terms of the report I'm
finished with that the only um the only
thing left uh is obviously the there's a
a letter of representation is the is is
almost part of the same agenda item um
again it's a standard thing that we do
um at every audit which is
just it's basically the committee
signing up to the fact that there's
nothing you haven't told us of about as
part of like you know in terms of our
records nothing's been kept from us
things like that
occasionally we might add something um
specific in there if there was something
that we were we' done a lot of work on
and we were maybe still kind of a bit
unsure there's nothing of that nature in
this one it's just standard letter of
representation
right super committee is Happy yourself
and myself chair we'll sign off the
letter and that will guarantee those
minimum standards right
so do I not have to just throw to the
committee that they're happy for me to
sign the letter of
representation so I'm happy to propose
from the chair I'm looking for a
seconder second you you got there first
all in
favor unanimous so
that's do you wish the account to be yes
right so just popping back to item uh
five I'm happy to move from the chair
that we approve the
accounts so I'm looking for a
seconder can I just can I just raise
something on certainly um I I don't
think it matters massively but um I
think that there is a mistake on page
10 um I don't know why but I think maybe
the row of a table is gone so it's the
utilization of surplus and capital
expenditure and if having a look just
just crosschecking it with what was
agreed in CNR I mean the numbers don't
add up if you add up the numbers in the
column you you get
753 not 853 and all of those numbers are
in the wrong place so it was 293 for
houses 150 for The Apprentice fund and
then 100 100,000 for agency backfill
76,000 for The Graduate 50,000 for the
election Reserve so somewhere in that
tiny in the narrative report Table there
must be a row that slipped out and the
numbers
of I think it's on page seven or eight
for me I've got P so it's on page eight
of your report and page 10 of the report
pack for us yeah and so at the bottom
table the utilization something's
missing um this the the numbers are not
in the correct place so there's it was
£100,000 for agency backfill that's
where the mistake that's where the first
mistake comes in and then it's £76,000
so all those figures need to drop down
£76,000 for The Graduate £50,000 for the
eltion reserve £30,000 for the plow
90,000 for lease cost £1 13,000 for the
pilot boat and then £51,000 for the
management fee for Act of forage that's
been missed off
it's just I think a presentation thing
okay but it was revisit that
okay
so with that correction with that
correction Lauren you're happy to second
second so if we just take a vote all in
favor and that's unanimous so we've
sorted out items five and
six
um it's from um a long time ago
September
so just back to the
agenda I need not um exclude the public
because we have no part two
matters so part eight doesn't apply or
item eight doesn't apply so with that I
can
formally